welcome back to the series
on getting started on LinkedIn.
let's start with the basics
of making your professional profile.
okay, let's start with this top section here.
you're gonna wanna select a profile picture
that looks professional
but also approachable,
like you're someone who
people would want to network with.
so basically,
alongside my passport photo,
I also took my LinkedIn photo.
the only difference is that
I'm smiling in my LinkedIn one and not in the passport.
then to make it professional,
I think it's pretty safe that
to just whack on a black and white filter.
okay. and then for your background,
I found that people often go for an architectural
representation of the industry they want to work in.
so you can see from mine
that is based pretty much on the city,
corporate world.
or if people are students are unique,
they will often go for a nice picture
of some sort of architecture at that campus.
I think it's a really good thing to
include your pronouns.
so I put mine in just here.
they are she, her.
and for your title,
it should reflect your current professional life.
so for instance,
you could do year 13 student at X school.
sometimes people also put aspiring X,
cause after seeing that,
people might reach out offering experience or advice
on that. okay,
part 2 will be on the next sections of your profile,
so follow for that.